T
WHEN SHE SAW IMAGES OF HIM I
COURTROOM,HEHT QUOTE THE
AS BEEN DETHRONED. HNOLE BUT EVS
THR D
HIF  THIS ,E'NGS AT T SCOUNSEVET
FERAAT INTLT W.
IT'S THE PROBEFORMER
PRESIDENT'S POTENTIAL
DOCUMENTHAT PARTICULARLY
COERER. MY UNDERSTAND
HA A PRESIDENTIAL RECORDSICH WAT
CARL BERNSTEINTHOR
CHASINGE
NEWSROOMND CNN CHNEANRO HSECH.
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT ISNG OR
LOOMING SO LARGE OVER THE FORMER
ENT'S LEGAL FAITH. WHAT
NG BECAUSE, AMONG
SIDENT
THE UNITEDTES ANDS G THESIODHE C
IT TO TAKE A
LITTLE B O IN THE
FOOW WAY WITH WHAT YOU SAIDHISYI
BUT IN FA HE HAS THREE
BEARINGON
TRUMP LEGALLY
TH TPEOSTIOS 6THUR
LOOKING AT, AND THAT
IS ON THE
HUGEES O
IN SEDITIOUSRYING TO STOP
TRAR OF POWER NEXT ID OF THUNIE
SENATE WATERGATE COMMITTEEDEVELO
THE IMPEACHNT AND
CONVICTION IN THEENEN RESIG OF D
NE JANUARY COMMI
ISHEDOS
DUNK RECORD. THAT IS SO IN TERMS
OF TRU LEGAL VULNERABILITY THATR
POTENTIALLY JOHNOR CT IT THAT TE
ESYENG
TIFY IN THE
DOCUMENT? B FIRST ALL LAWYERS AE
PRETTY GOOD WITNESSES. CHOMETHIT
THERAS A
PROBLEM FOR TCA,  THINK IS VERY
CA THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR OBSTRONJUSTICE, ANDBLEAU
SUBPOENA TO GO INMAR-A-LAGODUMES
SHOWN ALREADY THAT
THERE'S AE THEIMINALACTIVITYF SO
ORRIED.
CARL SMITH, AS YOU TALKED
ABOUT. I MEAN, HE'S JUST
INVESTIGATING THEUMENTS CASE
ALSO THE EFFORTSRN THE
NU 6TH OR THE FO
JANUARY, SUBPOENAE
NUMBERPE IN THE
V IER CIRCLE. FORMERWHITE HOUSS
MEAN, ESPECIALLY MEA HY
EXIV AWE
WE'REKI
IN THE DOCUMENTS. CASES ALSO
THE NU 1H CORRECTION CASEY
, AND YOU ALSO HAVENDYEO A VERYE
THAT SHOWS THA
TELEPHONEALDEDD TRUMP, WHILE
PRESIDENT OF EDS, SAID
TO THE SECRETARY OE E 11,000 VOG
AB A FAULTY
INTIMIDATION. THAT'SHE OTHER
CASE, SOIV ANG DOWN ON HIM AT OR
MOTIONSFTER
CASE
PRIVILEG N
ARE B TWO COMPELLEDG COMPELLED L
THIS WEEK IS JUSTNING J, SO WT
OF TERRIBLE CORRUEXT YEAR IS A
CONDUCT OOF AND ATTEMPT TO
STOP T LPOWER.S SUCCESSOR WHO WS
DU. THIS IS NOT ABOUT
TH IS ABOUT TRUMP
A WAY THAT NOAND STA
PRESTEDED ORDERLY
POWER TAKAC AS
TRUMP HAS DONE, AND THE FACTS
ARE THERE TUARY,TEE AND JOHN ONI
MEAN, IT'S INCREDIBLE. THE TO IE
PEOPLE WNG
K S,
GN . UM GOING A
THE THE CASE IN NKING A
POCSHETHE JUDGE'S DAUGHTER. IT'P
RULES  PROSECUTORS AND
TO FOLLOW
THEY CAN'T RESPOND
, ANDY FFGE
GE WAR IN, HE WARNED T'S THERE
ENHE PROBLEM
AND P H FOR THEFF FIFMPNG